[Musique]
hier soir ce pavillon a de nouveau été
le théâtre d'une fête illégale
il ya une semaine dans cette même maison
cet instinct un rassemblement sauvage de
300 à 400 personnes qui a eu lieu ici
avec des policiers qui avaient été pris
à partie lors ce qu'ils étaient
intervenus cette fois c'est bien le
maire de la ville a décidé il a pris
l'initiative de faire reposer un cadenas
sur la porte s'est fait interdite
tendent à se multiplier
samedi soir dans le xiiie arrondissement
de paris plus de 300 personnes dans ce
hangar désaffecté près d'une voie ferrée
l'entrée était payante 15 euros selon ce
participant
c'est d'une certaine manière mettre de
l'essence dans le moteur de l'épidémie
quand on fait des grandes concentrations
comme ça de 300 personnes
on a découvert ça sur les réseaux
sociaux après qu donc on n'a pas pu
intervenir sur le monde il ya un
problème d'acceptabilité manifestement
les explications n'ont jamais été sur
l'anglais est donc cette absence
d'acceptabilité j'en sors qu'il ya une
déprime permanente parce qu'on ne
comprend pas où on va
pourquoi on est là l'idée du présent la
république c'est surtout de pouvoir
donner des perspectives est donné en ce
sens rappelé à chacun que l'on va pas
être continuer éternellement mais que le
virus circule toujours et que donc il
nous faut nous adapter à la circulation
du virus est qu'il y aura des jeux en
français ou voulait conduisez exactement
où on va il y à des précautions à
prendre parce que le pire du pire ce
serait de ne desserrer l'étau trop vite
et puis après de devoir à nouveau se re
confinait repartir repartir dans
déconfinement dur on eu des consignes
pas limpide probable ouverture des
commerces dès samedi
c'est cela un peu présent non mais mais
baleine sherpa on sait bien c'est la
tendance vers laquelle le porte parole
du gouvernement donc bruno le maire
s'est exprimé aussi sur lucio calendrier
agissant sur la nuit le process de
nicolas sarkozy sur l' affaire des
écoutes commence aujourd'hui
l'ancien chef de l'état est jugé pour
corruption et trafic d'influencé
les conversations téléphoniques de
nicolas sarkozy avec son avocat thierry
herzog ont été écoutés pendant des mois
mi janvier 2014 ces deux amies depuis
près de 40 ans se parlent via des lignes
secrète ouverte au nom de paul bismuth
les enquêteurs les soupçonnent de
chercher à obtenir des informations
confidentielles dans le dossier
bettencourt d'un haut magistrat à qui
ils proposent leur aide pour obtenir un
poste à monaco
l'audience a été suspendue juste après
son ouverture le tribunal correctionnel
de paris a décidé d'ordonner une
expertise médicale de l'ancien haut
magistrat gilbert azibert 73 ans absent
à l'audience pour raisons médicales
gilbert azibert c'est l'homme sur qui le
pacte de corruption repose puisque c'est
lui qui est accusé d'avoir fait tous les
actes présumés délictueux c'est à dire
d'avoir été essaie d'obtenir des
documents confidentiels a essayé
d'influencer ses collègues de la cour de
cassation s'il n'est pas là en échange
d'un poste avons fait un bon poste à
monaco
donc s'il est pas là c'est plus
compliqué comment se fait-il que un
présent la république puisse être
écoutés dans le chef de l'opposition
puisse être écouté pendant près de huit
mois et que des graines ça c'est un
problème démocratique ya aucune preuve
c'est qu'on sait très bien qu'il n'est
pas intervenu à conques
baird a obtenu qu'une faveur donc le
dossier relativement vide à ce qui me
semble grave comme dans d'autres
demeurant cia qui a clairement un
acharnement une volonté d'humilier qui
se traduit que ce soit voulu ou pas
voulu par une intervention dans le
domaine politique
est-ce que vous pensez que cette affaire
va peut-être juste se terminer par des
dommages et intérêts à pôle bismuth pour
une notoriété qui n'avait pas demandé ce
serait sans doute l'échéance la moins
prévisible thermique de tics du procès
et après tout pourquoi pas aujourd'hui
c'est plus et la sphère sarkozy mme
sellah faire paul bismuth
j'attends rien du tout ce procès qui
vient ça m'est égal tout ce que je veux
c'est qu'on foute la paix